the Evil Dead can never die from the new
cast what the R rating means he has
everything you need to know about Evil
Dead rise let's go
originally Evil Dead rise was headed for
HBO Max but a Funny Thing Happened on
the Way to the streamer first David
zazlov decided to emphasize theatrical
releases after taking over Warner
Brothers secondly deadline reports are
when the film's trailer played at the
trade show Cinema Europe people ate it
up proving the film was good enough for
theaters so when can we expect to get in
line and buy some tickets well we'll get
to see Evil Dead rise at theaters on
April 21st 2023 as announced via Bruce
Campbell's Twitter account the actor
also shared a first look photo of the
film which showed a smiling dead eyes
leering through an apartment's
blood-soaked people interestingly enough
when Evil Dead rise releases in 2023 it
won't be the only horror comedy that
month the flick will be competing
against the Renfield which stars
Nicholas holds as Renfield and Nicholas
Cage as his master Dracula it'll be
interesting to see which horror comedy
walks away dominant
that's it
through all the Evil Dead franchises
there has been one constant someone
raised an evil book and unleashes the
forces of Hell in the first two Evil
Dead movies he watched his horror show
play out in a cabin in the middle of
nowhere with a group of young people
getting picked up and possessed by
sadistic Demons of course the big
difference between the two films is that
the Evil Dead is more or less straight
horror while Evil Dead 2 was much
heavier on the comedy
things get weird in Army of Darkness
when franchise hero Ash Williams goes
back to the Middle Ages to fight a
skeleton army and in 2013's Evil Dead
things get gorier than ever when a group
of friends hold up in a cabin and
release the deadites but what will Evil
Dead rise be about will it follow the
standard Evil Dead formula of a cabin in
the woods or will it get a bit more
creative Allah Army of Darkness well
this time the deadites are headed to Los
Angeles and they plan to unleash havoc
on an apartment complex the official
synopsis reads a road weary bath pays an
overdue visit to her older sister Ellie
the sister's reunion is cut short by the
discovery of a mysterious book deep in
the bowels of Ellie's building giving
rise to flesh-possessing demons and
thrusting birth into a primal battle for
survival
in the first three Evil Dead films a
franchise was anchored by the shotgun
toting chainsaw wielding Ash Williams
played by the one and only Bruce
Campbell Shop Smart
shop s mark
you got that in the 2013 installments
the focus shifted to Mia played by Jane
Levy a woman struggling with a drug
addiction who must also face an
onslaught from hell when she tries to go
cold turkey so who will be leading Evil
Dead rise Lily Sullivan will be playing
the lead role of Beth who goes to visit
her single mom's sister and finds
herself facing an apartment complex full
of dead Heights you may have seen
Sullivan in many series like picnic or
Hanging Rock or movies like mental
opposite her Alyssa Sutherland will play
Ellie the mother of three living in the
apartment complex whose life gets even
more complicated with the appearance of
the flesh-bound Necronomicon
the first three Evil Dead films are
famously directed by Sam Raimi who went
from micro budget filmmaker to
mainstream director on the success of
this Trilogy the 2013 Evil Dead was held
by fetty Alvarez who kept things intense
with his two other features don't
breathe and the girl in the spider's web
so who's in charge of all the Mayhem
murder and Madness this time around Evil
Dead rise will be directed by Lee Cronin
sure he isn't a household name yet but
we have a feeling he will be soon at the
moment Cronin is just one release film
to his name 2019's Uber creepy the hole
in the ground that film follows a single
mother in Ireland who suspects us there
might not actually be her boy anymore
raymie who's also the executive producer
on Evil Dead rise was so impressed with
cronin's work that he hand-picked him to
direct the new Evil Dead film speaking
with Slash film Remy said I loved the
hole in the ground I thought this was a
really great director and we met and he
talks and he said he really likes the
evil dead and I said then why don't you
make the new one I think you're just the
kind of guy like to do it that's High
Praise from the manukanja the Evil Dead
franchise into existence
the two people most closely associated
with the Evil Dead franchise are the two
who brought the series to life director
Sam Raimi and star Bruce Campbell
without these Titans of horror we
wouldn't have Ash Williams juking it out
with Undead monsters soaring off his own
possessed hand or reigning Supreme is
the king of esmart however neither one
would be reprising their original
positions for Evil Dead rise so will
these two be involved with Evil Dead
rise fortunately the answer is yes both
raymie and Campbell will be serving as
executive producers along with Robert
tupperts who's been involved with the
franchise since the first film and
Campbell has had nothing but positive
things to say about the film telling
collider Evil Dead rise does not suck in
the least Lee Cronin did a great job
it's a very European Evil Dead we're
assuming Campbell is referencing
European horror sensibilities although
we don't know if he's talking about
Italian jalo French extremity or some
other style whatever we're getting it's
sure to be scary Ray meets old slash
film it's terrifying and it's going to
knock people's socks off
if you know anything about the Evil Dead
series then you know it's not exactly a
PG rated franchise the first film scared
up the dreaded NC-17 with the subsequent
entries or earning and rating with their
severed Limbs and geysers of Gore so
what will Evil Dead rise be rated will
it compare to previous entries or let go
the root of so many modern movies and
play it safe with an audience friendly
PG-13 well never fear deadite die hards
Evil Dead rise is gonna keep things
nasty according to fangoria the 2023
film is officially rated R how come as
you might expect Lee cronin's upcoming
movie and the big bad are due to strong
bloody horror violence and Gore and some
language obviously you can't have an
evil dead film without delivering on the
kills well Army of Darkness isn't
exactly the hardest R but from
everything we've heard it seems likely
this one will have more in common with
the first two films and fetty Alvarez's
installment
if you're at work watch out the red band
trailer for Evil Dead rise isn't messing
around the trailer begins with possessed
mother Ellie cooking the world's worst
batch of scrambled eggs and describing a
lovely dream where she violently murders
a whole family clearly paging to the
Necronomicon and playing that old creepy
record her kid found was a mistake it's
always a mistake from there we watch
your scalps get ripped from heads
deadite swallows shards of glass and our
blooded hero Beth guarding a group of
poor kids from their very Undead mom
mom Mommy's with the maggots now yes
that Evil Dead staple the chainsaw does
make an appearance promising plenty of
severed Limbs and arterial sprays and
were also terrified to see what happened
to that cheese grater
when it comes to iconic horror
franchises few are as extensive as the
Evil Dead the series has five movies of
varying continuity a three-season
television series and multiple video
games and an entire three season
television series on Stars if you're
kind of like a young me that ice ruined
your life and your heart as hell thanks
of all this contents the Evil Dead
storyline can be a bit confusing for new
fans to rub their head around the very
first Evil Dead movie pits Ash Williams
and his friends against other worldly
demons while they're stuck in a remote
Woodland cabin with Ash as the only
Survivor his story continues into the
events of Evil Dead 2 and Army of
Darkness as he slowly and surely becomes
a dead eye killing chainsaw handed hero
let's talk about how I get back home
following his time in the Middle Ages
during Army of Darkness Ash spends the
next 30 years as a total loser working
at Value stop before accidentally
reading from the Necronomicon once again
to initiate the plot of Ash vs Evil Dead
now it's important to understand that
the world of Evil Dead rise is
supposedly linked to the original
trilogy rather than the 2013 reboot
titled Evil Dead some key elements are
carried over from what came before
however such as the Necronomicon and the
appearance of horrifying deadites
Evil Dead risers had a slightly
complicated development history as have
many installments in this franchise
since its Beginnings in 1981. this whole
mess started back in 2013 after director
Fede Alvarez was given free reign to
make his own remake of the original film
Evil Dead reimagine the events of the
first movie with an emphasis on
realistic Gore nuanced characters and
more modern horror additionally
completely new characters are added to
the Canon including new heroine Mia
Allen although Ash Williams himself does
make a small Cameo appearance on a
post-credits scene following the release
of Evil Dead Alvarez was slated to make
a sequel to his reboot with the backing
of Sam Raimi and Bruce Campbell but
things stalled as Alvarez found success
with his own original don't breathe
series The Uruguayan filmmaker even
tweeted a poll back in 2018 asking fans
which of his big movies had won to see a
sequel of and then expressed his
disappointments in the results he told
MovieWeb when I tweeted that I was
interested in seeing what people prefer
unfortunately Evil Dead 2 won which I
guess I would have preferred don't
breathe two to win because it's one of
my own Creations obviously Evil Dead is
a bigger following so that's what
happened it seems he ultimately decided
to go his own way since that proposed
sequel morphed into an entirely new
spin-off movie now known as Evil Dead
rise but that was Alvarez at the helm
there's something special about bloody
gory cult horror movies that gets
certain types of people frothing at the
mouth Evil Dead has proven to be one of
the most popular franchises of its kind
with seemingly endless fans inspired by
the way some Remy and Bruce Campbell
motor dramas of horror and comedy
seamlessly together Indie filmmakers
everywhere have cited evil dead as a
fundamental Touchstone of their own
desire to make no budget movies with
some pretty big names in entertainment
pointing to Remy's work as inspiration
such as Peter Jackson and Edgar Wright
even filmmakers as prestigious as the
Coen Brothers got their start editing
for some Remy on the Evil Dead at least
Joel did according to the story The
filmmaking style of the Evil Dead even
left an impact on the Cohen's own work
most notably in their films Blood Simple
and Raising Arizona that said this is a
franchise that has consistently produced
commercially successful and critically
acclaimed content that fans can't get
enough of overall the franchise has made
over 150 million dollars on a relatively
small budget furthermore the films are
recently screened at Fan events and
around Halloween which shows just how
much people love to see dead eyes get
cut in half with a chainsaw the newest
installment will no doubt be Justice
foreign